this morning ideas that matter our
series with ted and today we're sharing
a special message to families it comes
from one of the youngest people ever to
deliver a ted talk eight-year-old molly
wright shows how families can help
children thrive by playing simple games
like peek-a-boo
our brains develop faster in our early
years than at any other time in our
lives
it can create up to one million year old
connections
every second
but we need your help our healthy
development depends on these top five
things
one connecting two
talking three playing four a healthy
home
five community
all of this helps our brains and us
reach our full potential
this young lady is spot on molly's talk
was produced in collaboration with
mindaroo the foundation that helps
people thrive by five it's an initiative
and the goal is to raise awareness about
early childhood development molly joins
us now all the way from australia and
guess what it's her eighth birthday
happy birthday molly how are you doing
thank you so much i'm doing good how are
you doing
i'm doing really good now you say that
games like peek-a-boo can help children
thrive why do you say that
um
it's true because
simple games like peek-a-boo
they can help
um kids
thrive by five they can help they it
helps their development
hey molly uh it's tony here
it took a long time to memorize a speech
like that a lot of research a lot of
practice
how much went into this yeah
well
we googled ted talks and i watched a few
to get the idea of how i present it and
what
get the idea of what it was
and then
i practiced my lines um
the script
um
every night before bed and i've got like
a bunk bed and i and i blue tacked
the
um the sheet
to the top of it so i can lay under it
and read it when i go to bed without
having to hold it up
um so i can just read it before i go to
sleep and it gets stuck in my head molly
i'll just say this you did a great great
job i was taking notes from you because
they've asked me to do a ted talk and
i'm too nervous to do it but i was
watching you and i thought if molly
could do it maybe i could do it but this
is what i like most about your talk
my favorite daughter is having a baby
later this month we're very excited in
september and i think your ted talk was
so important for new parents to see but
i actually think all parents could learn
something from your talk what's the main
thing you want parents to know
i want them to know that
it's not all about putting down your
devices
like not going online at all because of
course we know that
you need to work from home
some parents need to work from home
on their devices
because of covid and we know they it's
really important and they depend on
their devices but we don't want to stop
them from going on their devices
occasionally if they need to
it's just
um to realize that your child's there in
the room and ready to play and if they
give you a serve make sure you return
and if you need to you can mess a few
serves but not all of them a serve is
just a scientific way of saying connect
talk and play with us on a return is
just returning it hey molly uh you've
done something amazing here your talk
has been viewed about 21 million times
pretty soon i think it's going to be
viewed more than there are people in all
of australia
i i want to ask you about the reaction
from your
classmates if there has been one
well
the reaction from
my classmates
it was really nice to be back at school
and
yeah i was really happy to see all the
my friends and they were really happy to
see me
um i've made a load of really close
friends at my class
so
it was nice to see them again and like
play with them
yeah um and we watched the ted talk
where do you go from here molly
i want to do another ted talk
i want to do it all over again molly
what are you going to do for your
birthday today i hope you're going to
have a piece of cake what are you going
to do
i've had my birthday already it's night
time here
oh hi
that's right with the time change you're
right you're right almost 9 o'clock
molly congratulations on your ted talk i
look forward to your next one thank you
thank you
good night
good night molly